le nouveau casque de Sony pour la
PlayStation 5 vient de sortir c'est le
playstation VR2 alors toi qui est super
intéressant pourquoi je vous le mets
dans l'île et bien tout simplement parce
que il est vraiment dédié à votre ps5
avec un suivi de vos yeux ça c'est
vachement cool ça fera plus d'émotions
lorsque vous allez venir jouer vous avez
en plus un petit moteur directement
intégré au casque qui fait que vous
allez ressentir ce qui se passe l'idée
c'est pas de gauche et Voltaire contre
les murs mais quand même d'avoir des
sensations on se parle aussi bien
évidemment dans le casque vert ça on
l'aura compris 4K HDR avec un champ de
vision de 110 degrés en plus de ça on a
le dos 3D pour venir apporter en terme
d'immersion en termes de spatialisation
ça c'est très chouette c'est comment il
fait intuitive au tarif modique de 599 €
99 € ça fait un certain prix bien
évidemment mais si on a envie de
s'amuser d'augmenter l'expérience sur
votre TS5 passer en VR avec les jeux qui
vont derrière et bien ça vous coûtera un
petit billet comme ça assez marrant dans
l'idée j'aime bien laver alors moi j'ai
du motion x donc je joue pas forcément
et c'est peut-être votre truc d'ailleurs
dites-le moi dans les commentaires
est-ce que vous pourriez succomber oui
non dites-moi ça je veux tout savoir